[Music]
in cheesy survival news you survive our
pizza Oh nobody time if I was on an
island and they just started dropping
off a pizza at me I'd be pretty happy so
you want them just to drop off pizza but
not to save you from the situation but
you don't to return to see your son yeah
well I thought I was with my son and my
wife don't drag me into your misery dude
that Island whatever it's a nice island
let me tell you the Hawaii anymore oh
you take me yeah I can take myself no I
always take you right now we're the view
audience yeah some general a stupid [ __ ]
about women I love that [ __ ]
Ariana guys like this yeah
I'll see your father isn't in the Butte
it's the real the real Tamar Braxton and
the other even more get off ya the
sister I think was a little a little
more balanced it's more balanced than
the real balanced the views balanced
more than the real than the real real
real it's like the ghetto view yeah as
the ghetto beer with the bacon it sounds
funny as [ __ ] yeah in the views nah but
her face is yeah Jenny my that's it yeah
yeah she's like that she's like the
token non black girl that hangs out with
the black girls yeah dude the view is
like somebody says a girl girls don't
need no man and then it's like seven
minutes of standing applause like that's
the first time they've ever heard
[ __ ] love that [ __ ]
a woman had to live on cheese slices for
weeks after her husband died at first I
was like did American cheese is it
because what her husband cooked
everything and she didn't know how to
cook no because there was this error
that also marked her and being deceased
as well and so she wasn't getting hurt
her weekly check I mean she could have
been like I'm here [ __ ] government
I'm too proud and too embarrassed to ask
for help oh my oh she retired
yeah she's 76 years old also she's
waiting for those checks to come in and
there's now pride as a 76 year old
person as I get older my pride
disappears
really my parents my grandparents and
parents have the most pride of anything
so maybe the way the older we become our
pride gets bigger maybe it's just
different days that say it that way the
same way because they have it James
mines decreased so like me and junior
high you bumped my shoulder I don't give
a [ __ ] you just [ __ ] with me and I look
throwing downs right security abort mask
my priority right then in high school it
was like you have to talk some [ __ ] to
get into a fight now if someone [ __ ]
knocked me the [ __ ] over at LAX and all
my [ __ ] spills out of my luggage on my
oh [ __ ] my bad
and I'll just pick it up and I'm just be
on my merry way like I don't have any
pride piss on my face I don't give a
[ __ ] that's why I love all this [ __ ]
where it's like if you just look at
somebody for names like hey are you
disrespecting me right now it's like
hard is easy here we go no private been
staring at me you been looking at me for
the past hour
right like nothing nothing I'm like not
[ __ ] happens after somebody says are
you disrespecting always [ __ ]
[ __ ] after that a hundred percent
disrespect to me Brett it's like the dog
park when you have two doggies that
stare at each other yeah they don't know
where they stand so they start growling
the two unsocialized ones yeah I feel so
done because like I genuinely enjoy
going to new bars yeah only because you
know it's like a new experience however
there's no that's always gonna happen
always it's always gonna happen yeah but
it's a great stories unless you go to
war being stared at yeah unless you go
to bars and silver.look my friend cuz n
is just hipsters who are trying to show
off a different kind of beer that
they've never heard of but it's like oh
no no I'm into this kind of sculpt in
because I got nobody's ever heard of
this more and then somebody else is like
oh whoa I like The Pale Ales are
nobody's heard of everything have you
ever had this cherry peach pills or
Hefeweizen
with a hint of strawberry it's like go
[ __ ] yourself you old ring course
instead just to get out of either be in
that group than the [ __ ] Barbarian
group oh yeah for sure oh yeah it's a
lot more safe don't some of them don't
even drink but they like going to bars
so they can find people to fight Wow
even now your honor that barbarian group
that was before like they would go and
then they were just like yeah let's just
look for people and then they'll make up
some type of excuse like amen I don't
like the way you were [ __ ] looking at
my brother because those do some funny
[ __ ] it's like you said like you just a
little bit of elbow and it's like yo bro
what the [ __ ] man oh boy here we go
yeah just immediately I'll be a
deaf-mute on the spot really yep boom
like that that's really good I've never
heard that is a defense cent and they're
like that's dull hopefully or they're
like like why you talking so dumb to me
is cuz you think I'm dumb I look like
this and just start drooling like just
take your ball works Hey look you might
be offended but if it works it saves a
life I think that's what they don't know
is I like that's a ninjitsu skill
deception you know it's like what that's
martial arts full deception that ninjas
were taught that never taught is just
like it's like yo drew lit circus
singers they pulled on the masks and
they thought what you're looking at
[Laughter]
you're a piece of [ __ ] yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah that's like we got 10 pairs of
glasses
that's smart [ __ ] outsmart them
nonviolent self-defense techniques yeah
I got no pride beat me up kiss me in the
face oh yes so much to lose when you're
older - yeah you know so it's like who
the [ __ ] cares and if you're worried
you're worried about bigger things so
it's like what does this do for you to
spend your energy to care about this
[ __ ] right literally nothing you don't
smile I get more pissed if things happen
to my friends no oh for sure like if if
like I saw
yelling at you or something I probably
get more pissed than someone yelled at
me I'm so sorry oh that's true I saw
somebody yell at you I'll just go in my
car roll the window god I'm like it's
your unlucky day you [ __ ] with the wrong
person dude I didn't wanted to see this
I do this recording no no that's not
proper ID format bro
remember for worldstar it's always like
this ah that's right and IG TV - oh
that's true no another trying to make it
popular I [ __ ] up that's right so come
on it's gotta go on walls time I saw at
one time where somebody was writing a
note on Gio's car outside of the old bar
belt do you remember this oh yeah he
asked him not to do it and he literally
shrugged you off and went back on his
phone and started writing on a car again
he was like hey man I'm not gonna ask
you twice but if you do think I'm a [ __ ]
you up and I just went right into
Barbara over the place
oh [ __ ] is about to go down dude I think
back about I just wouldn't sign them
what you observe that's somebody you
have to find cover yeah you like
Australia during World War two cuz I'd
never see that somebody before
yeah that should scared me I love it
yeah yeah well this story was about to
lady though oh yeah what kind of Jesus
she liked to Tila knows little [ __ ]
know she was rationing herself like two
slices a day Kraft singles out of this
leftover cheese that she had from her
husband's funeral
she lost 28 pounds oh what a great
weight loss program so she had no money
she couldn't go v drive-through or
nothin Oh
so she went on a keto diet force I
didn't have any money I know I was I
need a bit of cheese in the house about
the cheese and I thought the chasing
another I was starving I was - sterling
weight and I also didn't know about food
banks or anything it was just kind man
policy gave me the information until
that time I didn't everything to me
except the cheese and water she didn't
she didn't know what to do
bitter husband just used to take care of
her August took care of all the stuff
yeah it does sound like she didn't know
what to do
see that's why they said that though at
that time back in the day like women
should know what's going on because the
guy controlled everything finances blah
blah blah blah so if he passes away the
wing would be [ __ ] so that's the case of
that but there are a lot of
seven-year-old women that worked and
that did all that stuff dude my grandma
did all classes she's like a candy store
and steal something and classy and put
together to like we go yeah yeah
probably paid off since back in the day
since we know she will call the Sheila
8090 okay that's true yeah and she was a
nice she was too weak to even go
upstairs so she used her husband's chair
lived she spent five weeks like that
until someone finally like one of her
neighbors they saw her and they noticed
how upset she looked and like how much
weight she lost and then she told them
that they accidentally marked her as
deceased - so she stopped returning you
know and then that person he ended up
taking her to a local food bank where
she got some emergency food and then the
spokesperson for the Department of Work
and Pensions because takes lately okay
they ended up apologizing to her and
like fixing everything and they they're
saying that they're gonna make sure that
that never happens to anyone again give
her her backed up checks to pay better
half dog and cookie she didn't want to
come off as like broke and it's
embarrassing
Brian Mooar yeah well it's good on the
neighbor for not giving his own food out
of his fridge there's a good on a
neighbor for being like huh yeah it
looks like Marian lost all the weight
yeah anyway
after week six yeah [ __ ] I guess she
doesn't have any kids or grandchildren
or anybody any mention of a kid is so
funny it was like he has us fridge full
of food is why I pictured it because I'm
gonna take you to a food bank it's what
you do best he like owns a restaurant
and I think we gotta go to the food bank
I wouldn't even know where a food bank
is you can know it's Costco the Costco
food bank yet I just imagine a [ __ ]
vault full of food yeah isn't it where
they give people like all those little
meals
yeah that's a like a suit condition or a
soup kitchen but I think the same thing
but it's it's in the UK oh yeah so let
go withdraw some food from the food bank
right yeah thanks oh yeah but this is
pretty like I guess it's very ironic
because they marked her as deceased and
because of that she was pretty much
starving to death dude how'd you like to
get a letter in the mail this is that
we're sorry that you died and it was and
you're that old already you're like
maybe I am dead dad you're just tripping
out like
I'm not like what is the what's up [ __ ]
you would do cuz now you're dead you can
get away with it but you took it morbid
like I'm a ghost hell yeah so being dead
is like alive but then no one feels you
to end if you're hungry and nobody's
talking to you and [ __ ] like what if you
you can live off the grid I would love
if the government told me I was dead cuz
not gonna start killing people
oh I never thought of it like that yeah
but all your enemies will probably be
dead too
who did you kill first I don't know oh
if you give me that right to do it yeah
oh my gosh um oh we got a couple you've
been waiting for that right to come and
then you know what to do senior citizens
will make the best assassins but think
about the actual application of that
actual senior citizen trying to kill
someone
they'll be the funniest [ __ ] move hey
you know dude that is the China lift
that lady's guys a movie hit man who his
retirement gets denied and now he has to
get back here yes to get me I go what
that actually has moved there actually
is a movie well equalizer - that's what
that is
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you movie I love
Denso bro go watch it you saw it because
I loved equalizer right just because of
Denzel right go watch equalizer - oh
it's a senior citizen that has to go
back to the no it's a two hour lift
commercial walk down really yes I will
quote this one part of the film he's a
lyft driver right you see the lipslide
working here and that he picks up the a
guy an old man and he goes lift off
who says lift off the passenger just a
plug-in lift up down at least Denzel
didn't say I was gonna be sadder than
the first hour the movie I thought it
was a live commercial and it didn't go
anywhere so everybody in the theater was
like what is the point of this film to
figure it out it's just Denzel
Washington picking people up a drop in
mom yeah and then okay oh he'll break
somebody's fingers the course it's kind
of like wait wait no but he does a
stopwatch thing - right it's placed so
oddly he doesn't like once there's no
precedents for it's just kind of like
okay three people don't know the
stopwatch thing is when he he he gets
into a bad situation yeah and then that
guy's like hey man you really [ __ ] up
like probably big time and then he's
like he's like one second we just start
my watching he starts to walk and then
he
and kills everybody in the room and then
he picks up the little clock and he
checks the time and then he turns it off
do you like this like I was so pissed at
the film i legit was gonna do a vlog
about it that's how mad I was it was
that bucket there's this one random guy
by the way it was a French cop this is
how useless the scene is it goes like
this
mm-hmm there's a mercy here and the
French cop just goes maybe it's bad el
but it's what your scenes
anyway maybe it's what powder powder
that's all he says he goes yeah maybe
it's bad air switch scenes different
scene Wow
okay all right that's the official
review
[Music]